توفي صباح اليوم وزير الاعلام الكويتيه لا
يسبق محمد السنعوسي عن عمر النهزه 84 عاما
بعد صراع مع المرض سنعود من المؤسسين
لتلفزيون الكويت الرسميه عام 1960 وعرف
عنه تسليطه الضوء على سلوكيات الخاطئه في
المجتمع الكويتي ضمن برامج
اليوم بعد مشوار طويل
ولد السنعوسي في العام
1938 وتلقى مراحل تعليمه الاولى فيها قبل
ان ينتقل للدراسه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حصل على شهادته الجامعيه من
جامعه جنوب كاليفورنيا في الاعلام كما درس
النقد في المعهد العالي للفنون المسرحيه
في مصر يعد السنعوسي احد المؤسسين
للتلفزيون الكويت الرسمي عام 1960
للبرامج اضافه الى عمله كمخرج ومنتج ومعدل
البرامج ساهم بانتاج فيلم الرساله وعمر
المختار
وتدرج السنعوسي في تلفزيون الكويت حتى
اصبح في العام
1964 مراقبه للبرامج ثم مديرا عاما ثم
وكيلا بعيدا لشئون التلفزيون في وزاره
الاعلام حتى العام
الكويت بلد حار اكتسب السنعوسي شهره واسعه
ببرامجه الحواريه التي تتناول قضايا
اصلاحيه مهمه في الكويت كما عرف عنه
تسليطه الضوء على السلوكيات الخاطئه في
المجتمع الكويتي
ولانه شخصيه لا تعترف بالتقاعد بمعناه
الحرفي عمل بعد تقاعده من وزاره الاعلام
في العام
1985 عامل مديرا عاما لشركه المشروعات
السياحيه ثم استقاله وعمل بالتجاره الحره
قبل ان يصبح وزيرا للاعلام في العام 2006
وفي مارس من العام الماضي حل السنعوس ضيفا
على برنامج سؤال مباشر على شاشه العربيه
عبر فيه عن الكثير من ارائه التي كان منها
ان الديمقراطيه في الكويت منقوصه وان مجلس
الامه شر لا بد منه
طاقه على هذا المجتمع وللاسف الشديد فاصبح
مجلس الامه نقطه يشهر عليها
كانها شر ولكن لا بد منه
[موسيقى]